but watching the golden knights in the
playoffs yet again is absolutely
thrilling
and these fans say it's even more
exciting in an atmosphere like this with
fewer coveted restrictions
gold knights go knights playoff hockey
taking center stage in las vegas the
golden knights huge win
over the minnesota wild tuesday night
firing up fans at this watch party at
circa stadium swim
we love this environment so we wanted to
come out here and have a good time today
and watch the vegas nights on the big
screen i love the knights man i'm hoping
they win the whole thing
the electric energy turned up even
higher thanks to a sense of normalcy
circa announcing late last week that
they're back to 100 percent capacity and
fully vaccinated guests do not have to
have masks on it's a great feeling
being back out here not wearing masks
aim into that i'm happy to be vaccinated
and enjoying freedom right now
fans soaking up the night's victory and
taking in the sights and sounds of
fabulous las vegas
it's an amazing place it's an amazing
place to watch games
we love it beautiful absolutely
beautiful i'm glad everything is opened
up
everybody's having a good time that's
what's up fans are now looking forward
to game three of the first round of the
playoffs and hope the golden knights can
pull out a win
reporting from stadium swim at circa las
vegas orca mana 8 news now